so i have talked a lot about different
ways that you can visualize
multi-variable functions functions that
will have some kind of multi-dimensional
input or output
these include three-dimensional graphs
which are very common contour maps
vector fields parametric functions but
here i want to talk about one of my
all-time favorite ways to think about
functions which is as a transformation
so anytime you have some sort of
function
if you're thinking very abstractly i
like to think that there's some sort of
input space and i'll draw it as a blob
even though
you know that could be the real number
line so it should be a line or it could
be three-dimensional space and then
there's some kind of output space and
again i just very vaguely think about it
as this blob
but that could be again the real number
line the xy-plane three-dimensional
space and the function is just some way
of taking inputs to outputs
and
every time that we're trying to
visualize something like with a graph or
a contour map you're just trying to
associate input output pairs you know if
f inputs you know three gets mapped to
the vector 1 2 it's a question of how do
you associate the number 3 with that
vector 1 2. and the thought behind
transformations is that we're just going
to watch
the actual points of the input space
move to the output space and i'll start
with a simple example that's just a
one-dimensional function it'll have a
single variable input and it'll have a
single variable output
so let's consider the function f x
is equal to x squared minus 3.
and of course the way we're used to
visualizing something like this it'll be
as a graph you might kind of be thinking
of something roughly parabolic that's
squished down by three but here i don't
want to think in terms of graphs i just
want to say how do the inputs move to
those outputs so as an example if you go
to 0 when you plug in 0 you're going to
get negative 3 you know 0 squared minus
3 is equal to negative 3.
so somehow we want to watch zero move to
negative three
and then similarly let's say you plug in
one and you'd get one squared minus
three is negative two so somehow we
wanna watch
one move to negative two
and just to list another example here
let's say you were plugging in 3 itself
so
3 squared minus 3
is 9 minus 3 is 6. so somehow in this
transformation we want to watch 3
move to the number six
and with a little animation we can watch
this happen we can actually watch what
it looks like for all these numbers to
move to their corresponding outputs
so here we go each number will move over
and land on its output
and i'll clear up the board here
so i kept track of what the original
input numbers are by just kind of
writing them on top here
and that was a way of just watching how
it moves and i'll play it again here
let's let's just watch where
each number from the input space
moves over to the output
and with single variable functions this
is a little bit nice because it gives
this sense of inputs moving to outputs
but where it gets fun is in the context
of multi-variable functions
so now
let me consider a function that has a
one-dimensional input
and a two-dimensional output and
specifically
it'll be f of x
is equal to
cosine of x
and then the y component will be x sine
of y
sorry x sine of x
so just just to think about a couple
examples if you plug in something like
zero and think about where zero ought to
go
you would have f of 0
is equal to cosine of 0 is 1
and then 0 times anything is 0.
so somehow we're going to watch 0 move
over to the point 1 0 right so this is
where we expect 0 to land
and let's think about like pi
so
f of pi
and then cosine of pi is negative one
this is going to be pi multiplied by and
sine of pi is zero so that'll again be
zero
so you know this little guy is where
zero lands and we expect that this is
going to be where the value pi lands
and if we watch this take place and we
actually watch each element of the input
space move over to the output space
we get something like this
and again this is just kind of a nice
way to think about what's actually going
on you might ask questions about whether
the space ends up getting
stretched or squished
and notice that this is also what a
parametric plot of this function would
look like if you interpret it as a
parametric function this is what you get
in the end but whereas in parametric
plots you lose input information here
you can kind of see where things move as
you go from one to the other
and in the next video i'm going to talk
about how you can interpret functions
with a two-dimensional input and a
two-dimensional output as a
transformation